i'm rick
i'm megan welcome to the library
in 2004 we started opening it to the
public
and it became really a community
workshop as a community workshop
it's entirely community supported we
call this
an experimental research library it
fosters
experiments by people who may be artists
activists scientists
historians even academics but it's also
in itself an experiment
in preparing to shelve the library we
thought about different ways of
organizing book collections
one reason to have a physical collection
is
to support exploration-based research
the kind of exploration
that really relies on eyes hands
the sweep of your gaze in a geospatial
taxonomy
that kind of exploration-based research
is a natural fit
[Music]
we discovered the community built around
collections and the library community
has grown to thousands of people many of
them come to
events that are hosted here and what's
kind of cool is that nobody comes here
because they have to they come here
because they want to
um we're completely staffed by
volunteers the people who
have helped build this place or people
who
come in with just some visceral reaction
i have to work here i have to do
something here it's this
really amazing self-selection process
it's a place where you come to make
things we sometimes
think of it as a makerspace for history
over many years this collection has come
to serve a worldwide community of
researchers
of every kind we've been here for 16
years we hope to be here for many more
we hope you'll come visit join us in
this project
use this material as best you can for
your own work
become a part of this place
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
good morning this is the concert music
station
ksfr san francisco broadcasting
at 94.9 mega cycles
channel 235 from studios and offices
at 10 claude lane san francisco 8
california
ksfr is devoted to an exclusive concert
music policy
of presenting the world's greatest music
seven days a week
we trust you will choose to stay with us
as we commence another day of
broadcasting
the world's finest music
[Music]
the final score 41-800
[Music]
means bar tails and blaine's a w root
beer drive-ins on the peninsula
enjoy bartel and blaine's famous
king-sized papa burger
just enough size mama burger or the tot
size
baby burger perfect with frosty
delicious
a w root beer wherever you are on the
peninsula
you're close to a bartels and blaine's a
w root beer dry baby
so drive in
[Music]
one of seven good reasons why kya is
number one
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
b
you know in team job talk the phrase is
come and go
i've been hearing cool or coolant for
the past years
it might catch on then there's groove it
in the groove now i'm hearing super
i have some kids over mcclement's high
school the meaning of super superior
supreme a guy who eats a lot of soup
they said no jumping it's just a crazy
super
well whatever the case
ky a million dollar weekend side called
johnny good at seven and a half past
four
kya name it and claim it time know what
san francisco needs
another earthquake an earthquake that's
right not the 1906 kind
it's time to shake up san francisco it's
time to shake off the tired the old the
failing ways
it's time to stop talking talking
talking about our slums
our crime our transportation mess our
tax problem our school problems
our people against people tensions it's
time for the big
change time for a great mayor for san
francisco
you yes you can help support joe alioto
for mayor of the city that's at the
crossroads
which way will san francisco go with
your help
joe alioto will move san francisco
forward he has the courage to face our
problems
the experience to make decisions the
ability to get the job done
joe alioto native san franciscan one of
america's most successful lawyers
dedicated to building the san francisco
we want for our tomorrow
a great mayor is what san francisco
needs right now
joe alioto with your help can do the job
paid for by eliot from air committee
of all places housing artists in the
city the montgomery block has the oldest
tradition
behind these barrack windows george
sterling wrote some of his finest poems
frank norris wrote novels here
and so did charles and kathleen norris
once this massive building of brick and
stone contained san francisco's first
law library
once high-hatted wax mustache lawyers
and stock brokers
had offices here but in the 90s artists
began
the following sounds are samples of
jingles prepared for richard h
ulman incorporated by imn productions
no portion of this tape is licensed for
broadcast in any form
koby san francisco
[Music]
this is radio wonderful kobe
we've an obligation to you
you love koby san francisco
yes you do you're all bright excitingly
wonderful
kobe we've the best in listening it's
true so
from koby san francisco
from radio 1 san francisco
this is orson welles speaking from
treasure island in san francisco bay
some millions of americans came to a
world's fair here in treasure island
not so long ago and a million or so more
have come here since on more
serious affairs for this you know is now
a mighty naval station
a jumping off place for those who've
gone out to war in the pacific
and a reception center for the many
who've come back tourists and transient
sailors have had this much in common
anyway
a breathless view of bridge and sky of
ships come proudly to a proud city
and of the place itself the magic city
named for saint francis
who used to talk to the little birds
about the love of god
and to men about the brotherhood of man
when last i was here in san francisco it
was spring spring and the conference of
the united nations
seemed to hold the promise of a world
springtime the awakening of decency
between the governments
of justice among the peoples peace i
remembered looked
bright and green on the bud but now it's
winter again
and across the sea war which started in
a very distant sounding place called
manchuria
is still raging it's winter
spring and peace seem quite a ways off
today
today being the day after the day after
the fourth anniversary of pearl harbor
in the fifth month of the first year
of the age of the atom
governor miriam ladies and gentlemen
rarely perhaps never in my life
have i been as thrilled as i have been
today
starting with a visit to my old friends
of nearly a quarter of a century ago
at the mayor island navy yard
and then that trip by motor
over wonderful highways to that
view of your two new
bridges that i'd never seen
before that wonderful reception
all along the line of mine
i think i think
that you people out here on the coast
when you start to do something
do it better than anywhere else in the
united states
and its purpose is to assist him in
maintaining discipline within the police
department however the mayor
points out that the board serves only in
an advisory capacity
it transmits confidential reports on
complaints
to the commissioner and it is the police
commissioner
who retains all of the disciplinary
powers
and who is the final authority on all
decisions
concerning uh complaints against
policemen significantly of the four
civilians on the police review board two
or negro
won a puerto rican sports
the all-star game in st louis today the
best of the national league meets the
best of the american league indications
are the weather
is hot it may have a bearing kdia
sounds offense may not have been
as entertaining to some as the shriners
but his parade had more meaning behind
it
also i think that's good that's a good
way to hold a protest rally
uh it's better to enlist the support of
the
general public than it is to antagonize
and get into that
as you get farther that way faster thank
you for your opinion call the sound
offline at 834
6765 the kdia oakland weather forecast
for the san francisco
bay low overcast and local drizzle
through tomorrow morning
however clearing weather this afternoon
the high today around the bay
60 to seven we return you now to our san
francisco studios
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hallelujah
[Music]
open up
[Music]
so
after 100 years of operation the san
francisco mint is down to its last
scent with the exhaustion of copper
blanks the last batch of pennies rolls
out of the machines
minting of silver coins had been
suspended a week earlier
cost of transporting the pennies east
where they are mostly used
was given as the reason for ending penny
coinage
as the last lot whirls through the
counter old-time employees many with
more than 20 years experience look on
sadly
remembering the traditions which have
surrounded the mint the very last scent
from an institution which began in the
gold rush days
once capable of issuing a million and a
half coins a day
the mint falls silent
lewis freeman kdia news in this country
in civil rights development san
francisco the attorney representing san
francisco's 1964 civil rights sit-in
demonstrators
has asked the state supreme court to
stay their jail sentences
he bases the move upon the fact that 15
of the demonstrators have already been
jailed and unless the state supreme
court grants a stay
practically all of them will have served
their sentences by the time the united
states supreme court acts
civil rights groups are meeting in san
francisco at the macedonia missionary
baptist church it's anticipated that
they will announce their position
on the auto row arrest and sentences
in the north the reverend dr martin
luther king says that
demonstrations will hit chicago for an
extended period
that story is reported in detail by roy
wood
this is roy wood reporting to kdia from
chicago illinois where dr martin luther
king is calling for
nonviolent assault on the problems that
are being faced by negrez and this city
yesterday he had a meeting with mayor
daley that he reported as disappointing
the mayor charged with the civil rights
leaders didn't propose any constructive
suggestions from initial
reforms all they did was recite lists of
problems
dr king says the mayor rejected the two
major demands by the civil rights
leaders
the rights for a civilian review board
for the police department
and immediate action on housing for the
underprivileged
he's pledged a three-month campaign of
marches and direct action against
individual slump lords roy wood
reporting to kdia
from chicago over in the nation's
capital an iqbal
civil rights leader the reverend
cleveland sparrow says that the nation's
capital may see
more demonstrations and more violent
ones he indicates that at any time
summer violence could erupt in the
capital
unless something is done about the
flight the negro in the federal city
[Music]
what no job but don't worry i know what
they'll tell you
you're too young you're unexperienced
you're not in the union we can't bond
you you've been in trouble
you're not a graduate we can't use you
but don't worry don't worry old lady
loser christmas money
purse will be snatched some old man will
be knocked down
and everybody will wonder why
people but if they don't see you fight
it's hearsay that's so they believe it
because you're in a club and you wearing
a club jacket
so you're a thug right away to the
public then
you know what is but it's some people
that realize
that uh you know that by being in a club
but it can be a good thing and a club
can be a bad thing
yeah but yeah but you have to start off
with the right thing
to end up right in spite of some initial
opposition concerning
law and order
the party did go off quite smoothly
after all
enjoyed by several hundred youth for
service participants and their dates
[Music]
only one slight mishap was reported a
policeman
somehow lost his badge
[Music]
the sound of the city the psalms that
are burning sand
transits
are mixed with daylight
[Music]
when darkness settles
chimes ringing softly in the stillness
[Music]
fought creeping slowly across the bed
[Music]
on
san francisco
you